so Money Boy wir haben uns gedacht wenn
es dreht den zack auf heißt wo kann man
es besser als im redison Blue super
nettes Hotel wo wir sehr oft sein können
die super nett und eben hammermäßig
komfortabel also swagisch kann man das
so sagen sind jetzt stellt mir im
redison der her Fragen money Bo bald
schon im Micon Square
Garden bit
schön
wie ist die
Lage die Lage ist super ich komme gerade
von einem Auftritt im Karnevalszelt in
Köln ist super gelaufen ich habe gleich
Afterparty gemacht ich habe ganz auf
unser Interview vergessen bis ihr mich
dann abgeholt habt und so aber die Lage
ist nach wie vor super ich fühle mich
great war das also du gemerkt hast dass
ich dein Leben ändert wie war das der
Moment boah das war nicht so ein
bestimmter Moment es ging so
schrittweise
und ich weiß nicht ich ma das ich mache
die Dinge einfach und im Moment nehme
ich mir gar nicht die Zeit oder habe gar
nicht die Zeit da so sehr zu
reflektieren weil ich einfach in einer
Tour meine Dinge mache meine Videos
meine Tracks meine Medientermine meine
Auftritte und ich genieße einfach den
Moment und das ist das Gute ist wenn du
dich in so einem Ding so richtig
verlierst dass du gar nicht mehr so
bewusst denkst und aufpasst auf so Dinge
wie vom verändert sich mein Leben
sondern das dann kannst du am am natür
en genießen wenn du einfach in der Sache
aufgehst und bei mir ist das im Moment
total der Fall und du bist happy damit
so wie es ist ja ich bin sehr happy
damit das war mein Traum ich habe ich
höre seit ich 13 bin HipHop in früher
auf CDs im disman den ganzen Tag ich bin
herumgegangen auf der Straße hab die
Sachen mitgerappt habe dazu die
Bewegungen gemacht man hat mich es ist
glaube ich kein Tag vergangen an dem ich
nicht irgendwelche raptracks gehört habe
und ich habe natürlich immer davon
geträumt selber so ein Rapper zu sein
auf der Bühne zu stehen im Fernsehen zu
sein berühmt zu sein und ich habe es
geschafft natürlich in Realität fühlt
sich dann immer etwas anders an als in
den Träumen das das Gute an träumen
dass sie mir nicht mit der Realität zu
vergleichen sind und so aber auch auch
in der Realität fühlt sich gut an und
ich bin sehr zufrieden damit und es geht
mir super was sagen denn die anderen
Kollegen muss man ja jetzt schon sagen
dazu weil das ja auch du schlägst ja
förmlich aus der Art die wollen sich
möglichst knallhart und Jungs von der
Straße geben du genau das Gegenteil
m ja ich gebe den vielleicht eine neue
Perspektive
oder ich steck die vielleicht auch an
mit meinem Swag die können sich auch was
abgucken ist ein bisschen frischer Wind
und ich habe schon von vielen Leuten
auch in der Szene ich habe heute erst
telefoniert mit Curs die Freundin von
Kurs habe ich jetzt getroffen bei meinem
Auftritt wenn es so stimmt wenn das nur
ein Witz war und gar nicht KST war dann
sorry dann stimmt die Sache nicht aber
ich hatte schon das Gefühl dass er es
war und so der gibt mir auch Props und
sagt der hat Spaß an meiner Musik der
hört sich das gerne an ich habe von
allen möglichen Leuten die wirklich auch
was zu sagen haben Props bekommen die
Erfahrung haben in dem Game
und das hat viel mehr Bedeutung echoresh
hat ziemlich am Anfang von meinem Hype
schon gesagt so hey dieser moneyby hat
hat mir wieder mehr Spaß an Rap gegeben
der hat den Spaß wieder zurückgebracht
ins ins Rap Game das hat für mich viel
mehr Gewicht als wenn irgendein Rapper
vielleicht so angepisst ist und sagt so
dieser Money Boy ist doch kacke oder so
das ich lass mich lieber antreiben von
vom positiven Feedback und sauge diese
Sachen richtig auf und alle anderen
Sachen so lass ich einfach unter der
Brücke durchfließen water under the
bridge okay wenn du jetzt sagst
Spaß aber du sagst auch ich meine es
ernst klar doch überhaupt kein SP was
ist ernst also für mich ist das kein
kein Widerspruch und ich kann diese
Frage echt nicht ich kriege viele Fragen
gestellt und alle kommen bei mir
irgendwie an aber so immer bei dieser
Frage meint er das ernst oder nicht ich
weiß nicht ich würde ich stell mir diese
Frage bei anderen Leuten auch nicht
entweder ich fei das oder ich fei das
nicht aber ich ma mir nicht Gedanken wie
meint er das mir ist ganz egal wie das
irgendjemand anderer meint ich es muss
einfach Dope sein es muss cool sein und
ja natürlich meine ich das ernst ich
liebe Rap und ich liebe Rap aufrichtig
und
das was ich mache mache ich auch
aufrichtig und drum ist das ernst nur
wenn wenn man Spaß auch an das hat oder
vielleicht humorvolle lines hat oder so
HipHop ist hat immer mit Humor zu tun
Punchlines das kommt ja glaube ich fast
schon aus Comedy oder so eine Punchline
ist eine Pointe und Rapper wollen
Pointen bringen und so und da ist Humor
natürlich dabei das ist überhaupt kein
Widerspruch warum soll das nicht ernst
gemeint sein ich ma mein meine craft
mein Handwerk ich mache das vollkommen
ernst und ja die Kohle die ich dafür
Kriege ist auch echtes Geld kein
Monopoly Geld das alles was damit zu tun
hat ist ist ernst aber ich weiß nicht
keine Ahnung also
mein Leben ist generell nicht so
so ernst und so ich möchte einfach Spaß
haben ich möchte ja meine Zeit genießen
es ist ja schon was sehr Besonderes weil
du hast ja den Mut in Anführungszeichen
schief zu singen jeder andere Künstler
der nicht singen kann der sagt ich hole
mir audiotune rein du sagst aber das
mache ich zum Stil ja
weil ich mich nicht
orientiere an dem was andere Leute sagen
ich brauche nicht die Bestätigung ich
brauche nicht das jemand einverstanden
ist ich mache das worauf ich Bock habe
ich bin vielleicht kein Chris Brown oder
kein aser aber wenn ich Bock habe eine
eine Hook zu singen dann singe ich die
so gut ich kann oder vielleicht auch
nicht so gut ich kann weil ich es auf
einen take aufnehme und mir denkt passt
der Track ist im Kasten ich musste nicht
zehn mal aufnehmen weil das ein Mixtape
und das nächste Mixtape kommt bestimmt
da kann ich es besser machen warum soll
ich mich lange aufhalten warum soll ich
mich lange aufhalten wenn mich jemand
kritisiert oder wenn jemand das nicht
gut findet ich mache immer weiter und
beim nächsten Mal ist die Hook
vielleicht besser oder sie ist genauso
schief oder so aberi mir macht Spaß und
den Leuten macht's auch Spaß weil die
merken dass es auch wenn vielleicht
nicht die Töne getroffen werden merken
die dass ich das real rüberbringen und
das viicht im Endeffekt wichtiger als
wenn ich das wir ein ein
Computerprogramm oder wie keine Ahnung
irgendeine emotionslose Sängerin jeden
Ton treffe bei mir kommt zumindest was
rüber und das ist das Ding und ja ich
muss nur einverstanden sein mit meiner
Musik das ist mir das Wichtigste wenn
dann das alle möglichen anderen Leute
feiern umso besser aber in im Moment wo
ich das aufnehme dann bin ich die
einzige Barriere oder so die es gibt
aber es gibt schon Leute du hast es ja
angesprochen die das kritisieren frisst
sich das manchmal an wir kennen es ja
auch von Youtube man wird ja es gibt so
haterattacken frisst dich das an oder
wie geh ne ganz selten ganz selten
frisst mich das an und eigentlich ich
will nur Rapmusik machen ich will videos
machen alles was zu dieser zu diesem ich
sage mal so urban Entertainment gehört
ich will einfach alle diese Sachen
machen das ist was ich mir denke und so
und wenn ich dann dann weiter denke über
alles was andere Leute vielleicht zu
diesem Thema denken dann sage ich dann
habe ich vielleicht ein bisschen eine
größere message auch dass ich den Leuten
zeigen will so hey macht einfach das
worauf ihr Bock habt macht das was ihr
fühlt kommt aus eurer Shell oder aus eer
weiß ich nicht aus irgendwelchen
Einschränkungen oder so die ihr glaubt
die vielleicht da sind kommt einfach
raus und macht einfach euer Ding und
wenn da jemand hatet dann hatet jemand
dafür liebt euch jemand anderer man kann
es nicht jeden recht machen das ist ganz
einfache sind ganz einfache Regeln des
Lebens und die sind im Internet nicht
anders und irgendwo und ich führe den
Leuten das einfach vor ich mache meine
Musik und wenn da Leute hden dann sehen
meine Fans genauso dass Leute Haden und
die Leute die Haden sehen sich selber im
Spiegel weil ich ein commercial
rausbring moneyby commercial und die
haer adressiere hatet mich disst mich
sagt dass ich kein Talent habe und dann
sieht man mich wie ich ins Studio gehe
und Raap und trotzdem mein Ding mach
egal was die Hater sagen und so und dann
führe ich viicht den Leuten noch einen
Spiegel vor und zeige hey und gebt dir
noch eine Plattform he mich he mich so
viel ihr wollt postet und so aber es
wird nichts daran ändern dass ich mein
Ding weiterhin so mache wie ich es
machen will und trotzdem die Leute
erreiche und dann bringe ich vielleicht
Leute zum Umdenken weil die sich denken
hey wenn ich bei einer Party bin von
money Boy und dann Becher schmeiße und
rund um mich Blicke und das sind sexy
Ladies mit ihrem Freund oder mit ihren
Freundinnen und die haben alle ein
Lachen im Gesicht und die machen Party
und rappen mit und ich stehe da und
werfe einen Bächer dann frage ich mich
wer hat die bessere Zeit der mit der
negativen Energie und dem Hass oder die
die gut drauf sind und und dann ist das
vielleicht auch meine größere message im
Kern mache ich meine Rapmusik und in
eine bigger picture weiß ich nicht mache
ich alle möglichen anderen Dinge und so
und im Endeffekt wird das alles Sinn
ergeben und so und wer weiß was moneyby
alles bewegen bewegen wird und bewegen
kann ich bin gespannt für mich ist ein
aufregender Trip und ich ich fahre
einfach meine Schiene und wenn viele
Leute häden dann bin ich schon mal ganz
natürlich wie jeder andere Mensch auch
pisst und denkt mir so what the [__] was
soll dieser dis was ist
und so und dann rege ich mich kurz auf 3
Sekunden und dann ist die Sache schon
wieder vorbei es ist ja auch irgendwie
so ein bisschen paradox auf Youtube
einerseits wir alle auf Youtube wollen
gerade uns zeigen mit unseren Fehlern
und sagen Fernsehen ist ja Mist weil das
ist ja viel zu perfekt aber wenn wir es
dann zeigen dann kriegen wir ein auf dem
Deckel aber das ist ja letztlich der
Sinn der Geschichte dass wir hier auch
ein Interview führen was eben nicht bis
in jeden Punkt vorbereitet ist ich ein
Knopf im Ohr hab und ist genau die Sache
und das genau was was ich vorher im Kopf
habe weil ich komme gerade von meiner
Show ich habe alle möglichen
fernsehschen schon gemacht ich ich kicke
auch in die Kamera freestylesles ich
mache irgendwelche Sachen und das ist
alles nicht perfekt das ist nicht
gescriptet das ist nicht ein Drehbuch
das ist nicht so wie ich Musik Video
präsentieren würde so würde ich kein
Track aufnehmen weil das muss alles
natürlich einer gewissen Qualität
entsprechen aber es ist real einfach
weil es ist so du verrappst dich in
einem Freestyle D passen ein paar Sachen
nicht das real und ich brauch mich dafür
nicht verstecken weil jeder andere
Rapper würde diesen selben Fehler
genauso machen nur weil ich nicht
dahinter bin und sag das musst Du
rausschneiden und das machen wir noch
mal [__] ich bin real ich mach die
Sachen so wie ich bin ich habe jetzt
schon ein paar Drinks in und ich ich bin
gut drauf ich fühle mich gut ich ma
Party hier und ja vielleicht denke ich
mir morgen in der Früh so oh ich habe
alle zugelabert beim Interview schon
vorher mit Raps TV na und es ist so im
Moment und das einfach real und das
money Boy und ja das ist einfach viel
mehr real als RTL hey ihr kommt jetzt da
ins Haus rein und wir filmen dich von
vorne von hinten und dann begrüßt du
deine Freundin und die gib dir ein Kuss
und dann machen wir eine coole Story und
so ja what the [__] dein Twitter Account
heißt ja auch the real Money Boy und
nicht Mone aber apropos the real was
wärest du denn jetzt wenn du nicht Money
Boy wärst also wenn das nicht so
passiert
wäre also ich wä im Grunde ich hätte den
den viicht nicht denselben Swag weil
dieses Ding was ich jetzt mach dass ich
vor so vielen Leuten Spiele dass ich so
im Mittelpunkt ST pusht ganz ehrlich
gesagt natürlich dieses Gefühl von Swag
was ich schon paar mal erklärt habe das
pusht das natürlich und beflügelt einen
alle möglichen Sachen zu machen
vielleicht hätte ich nicht dasselbe ge
fühl aber ich würde nach wie vor Rappen
meine Texte schreiben die Musik hören
und nebenbei einfach meinen Job machen
den ich vorher gemacht habe einfach als
Redakteur in einer Medienfirma möchte
ich nicht zu sehr drauf eingehen weil
das auch nicht so interessant ist und
dann würde ich das machen und nebenbei
würde ich trotzdem meine Klamotten
shoppen und statt dass ich dann auf die
Bühne gehe würde ich so in den Club
gehen und trotzdem fly sein und cool
sein für mich selbst für die Leute die
mich kennen und einfach Spaß haben mich
cool anzuziehen meine Texte zu schreiben
die aufzunehmen ich würde die releasen
und wenn die nicht so viele Leute hören
meine Tracks ich die trotzdem auf
Youtube hätte ich 200 Klicks da undten
dann würde ich meine Mixtapes machen auf
auf auf auf niedrigem Level und ich
würde das selbe Ding machen ich wer halt
nicht jede Woche in Deutschland ich
würde nicht vor allen Kameras sein hätte
ein bisschen mehr Freizeit wer
vielleicht jetzt gerade in New York oder
so und wird wird's mir dort gut gehen
lassen und so weiter geht jetzt leider
nicht ich will schon lange bisschen
Urlaub machen und so ich bin so viel
gebuckt und so da muss ich es immer
verschieben aufs nächste Monat aber ich
freue mich wenn die Bookings kommen
verschiebe ich New York und wenn die mal
nicht drin sind dann weine ich nicht
weil jetzt kein booking gerade für das
Wochenende ist dann freue ich mich dass
ich irgendwo hinfliegen kann aber
trotzdem du hast gerade noch mal gesagt
Herz so an die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen
mit seiner
Person wird man nicht auch öfter mal
auch verletzt ich sag nicht nur von
Hatern sondern auch von Leuten mit den
man zu tun hat die ein sagen was machst
du denn da also dass man auch verletzt
wird weil was vorher hast du in einem
stillen Kämmerlein gemacht ne da hat da
war vielleicht auch Selbstschutz aber
jetzt gehst du mit dem an die
Öffentlichkeit und sagst hier bin ich
und so bin ich ja und ist das manchmal
so
ähm ja es gibt schon manchmal Momente wo
man wo man sich verletzt fühlt so wie du
sagst
m klar ich meine es einerseits gibt's
diese mediensache da wenn manchmal
Sachen aber das kennt man ja vom vorne
rein vor allem ich ich komme ja auch aus
diesem aus diesem mediending und Ken
mich auch weiß es aber man kennt es noch
nicht das stimmt man weiß es aber man
kennt es noch nicht und so ich war lange
Zeit wirklich auch relativ immun ich
glaube das ist so ein bisschen so dass
man das so anfängt so ganz unten und so
man kann das noch alles gut abblocken
aber je mehr das wird irgendwann
überwindet es doch doch dann einen
kritischen Punkt und dann kommt an einen
heran ich habe in vielen Interviews
gesagt das kommt nicht an mich ran weil
es wirklich zu dem Zeitpunkt auch so war
und manche Sachen treffen mich schon und
man man verändert sich auch ständig
irgendwie so im mindset einfach am
Anfang macht man einfach die Dinge und
man muss ständig irgendwie mit neuen
Dingen lernen umzugehen und so und dann
irgendwann das ist bei jeden so
irgendwann macht man sein Ding dann
versteift man sich auch auf bestimmte
Sachen glaubt man um erfolgreich zu sein
um weiterhin den Halbarm zu heizen muss
ich das machen dann glaubt man ich muss
auf die Leute hören dann nimmt man sich
auf einmal das zu Herzen was irgendwo
anders steht und so und dann lass man
total viele Sachen auf sich dann und
dann erreicht man irgendeinen Punkt wo
man sich denkt und jetzt scheiß auf all
das ich besin mich auf das was ich am
Anfang gemacht habe und mache einfach
das und dann kriegt man irgendwie so
einen neuen Push und das beflügel einin
wieder das alles irgendwie so ein
Prozess und so manchmal sind
frustrierende Momente kommt man
vielleicht zurück von irgendwas von
irginer Show die auch vielleicht gut
gelaufen ist aber irgendwann denkt man
sich so hey aber das hat mir nicht das
Feeling g gegeben was ich vielleicht
irgendwann mal anders schon hatte oder
was ich gern gehabt hätte und dann ist
man vielleicht total down dann ist man
irgendwie pisst auf alles und D Fick auf
mein Label Fick auf Fick auf die Hater
Fick auf alles und so dann scheißt man
auf alles und so dann vergehen ein zwei
Tage und so dann denkt man so und jetzt
komme ich von dem das sind so Sachen die
spielen sich eiglich im Kopf ab das ist
nämlich gar nicht die Realität weil die
Leute schauen sich trz deine YouTube
Videos an die feieren das trotzdem aber
im selber erlebt man so rauf und runter
rauf und runter und so aber ich meine
das auch das was spannend macht und ich
nehme die Sachen einfach so wie sie sind
und egal was kommt ich nehme das als als
Challenge und ich h mal Moment wo du
gedacht hast ich hö auf nein überhaupt
nicht
das warum ich ma das nicht für für
irgendwelche Medien ich ma das nicht für
100000 Leute die ich nicht kenne sondern
weil mir das am meisten Spaß macht
und ich würde nie aufhören ich will das
ist das Ding wenn alles schlecht läuft
wenn wenn angenommen wenn alles schlecht
läuft dann lege ich einen raptrack auf
und hör den an und fühl mich da rein und
schreib selber ein paar Zeilen und dann
kann es sein das habe ich auch schon
gemacht die habe ich noch nicht
veröffentlicht es gab auch Momente wo es
scheiße gelaufen ist wo mich auch eigene
Freunde vielleicht teilweise so Zweifler
an mir hatten und so und da da war ich
auch wirklich down und so und dann habe
ich irgendeinen für ein bisschen
melancholischeren Beat gehört oder so
und dann habe ich auch solche Sachen
geschrieben und so das ist so wie eine
kleine Therapie oder so da habe ich das
von meiner Seele geschrieben und so und
äh egal also wenn ich selbst dann alle
Stricke reisßen oder so da habe ich
immer noch Rap und dann kann ich immer
noch ein Beat anhören und kann immer
noch Eintauchen in diesen Flow das
gibt's ja so ich habe ja studiert und da
habe ich das auch mal gehört es gibt so
Art diesen Flow wenn man sich mit
irgendeiner Sache so beschäftigt dass
man alles rund um sich vergisst und in
einer Sache aufgeht und das bei mir wenn
ich einen raptext schreibe dann ist mir
alles egal dann höre ich nur den Beat
dann habe ich nur noch meine Gedanken
und dann ist mir egal ob ich und top of
the game bin ob mich alle feiern ob alle
gut über mich schreiben oder schlecht
dann schreibe ich meinen raptext und das
kann niemand verhindern g dann du hast
gerade gesprochen dass auch Freunde
vielleicht dich kritisiert haben oder
Abstand davon genommen haben macht
Erfolg einsam
macht mich nicht einsam
weil ich
ich habe eine Freundin die allen meinen
Sachen bei mir
ist und drum könnte ich kann ich mich
nie einsam fühlen dass das Gute es
sicherlich ich habe auch schon von
manchen Stars gehört
oder gelesen und so dass sie total
einsam sind manchmal und so aber ich
habe das glückt dass ich wirklich paar
ich bin vielleicht jetzt im Moment ich
man kann nicht mit so vielen Leuten
Kontakt haben wenn man so viel zu tun
hat und und so ein Lifestyle hat wie ich
im Moment kann man nicht mit allen den
Kontakt haben und kann nicht alle
zurückrufen kann man vielleicht schon
aber da muss man einfach sagen so und
ich rufe den jetzt nicht zurück und ich
rufe den nicht zurück weil
man kann man weiß man kann sich nicht
mit denen treffen man weiß man es passt
im Moment nicht duum muss man das mal
wegschieben und dann kommt schon wieder
die Zeit dann kann man auch wieder auf
diese Leute zurückkommen ich weiß dass
ich gute Freunde hab die mir das nicht
übel nehmen wenn ich jetzt auch
vielleicht mich zi D Monate überhaupt
nicht melde wissen die nicht D wissen
die dass ich nicht auf die Scheiße oder
so dann wissen die
m das jetzt einfach nicht die Zeit dafür
ist und ich habe ich fühle mich
überhaupt nicht einsam und äh ähm ja das
freut mich einfach dass ich in dieser
Situation bin dass dass das keine keine
der negativen Seiten von meinem Erfolg
ist dass ich jetzt einsam wäre oder so
zum Glück nicht aber dass man mal denkt
hey ich würde jetzt gerne mal zu Hause
sitzen mit ein paar Freunden Bier
trinken statt mit dem blöden krachten
hier zu sitzen
m nein weil das das habe ich oft genug
die Sachen kennt man ja alle das hat man
oft genug gemacht mit Freunden
Fußballspiel schauen bisschen zocken und
alle möglichen Sachen bisschen in Bball
spielen und so viele Leute sagen hey
weil ich habe ja lange Zeit Basketball
gespielt hey komm gehen wir mal wieder
zwe zweite Bundesliga erste Bundesliga
war ich auch mal in einem Team und
die Leute fragen so he willst du nicht
wieder mal spielen gehen und so und und
das Ding ist ich habe so viele Jahre das
gespielt ich habe so viele Jahre mit
meinen Jungs gechillt und alles mögliche
gemacht ich kenne das alles und das kann
man alles wieder machen aber diese
Interview Sache alle das das relativ neu
für mich und so und drum denke ich mir
eigentlich es war ist cooler jetzt mit
diesem krachten zu sitzen als füricht
Spiel im im Fernsehen anzusehen gut das
freut mich sehr ich danke dir erstmal
ja das war das Interview und jetzt
kommen die anderen Parts okay
cool